شكرًا لك، سيدي الوزير، إنه لمن دواعي سروري أن
أكون هنا، دعني أطلب منك أن تبدأ بـ
أه بي بي نتنياهو، كان رئيس وزراء
إسرائيل على شاشة سي إن إن للتو ويقول اقتباسًا أود
أن أرى الأمم المتحدة الأمين العام للأمم المتحدة
الذي وضع أساسًا  إلقاء اللوم على
إسرائيل إلقاء اللوم على هؤلاء المتوحشين
لمطالبتهم بالامتثال للقانون الدولي
لأن إسرائيل تقاتل وفقًا
للقانون الدولي ما هو رد فعلك
حسنًا، هذا ببساطة غير صحيح أعني عندما
تكون في الأمم المتحدة وتواجه
وضعًا فظيعًا
وفوضوي مثل ديساس يجب أن تتمسك
بالمبادئ وأه منذ
البداية لقد أدنت أما
ما فعله أماماس فهو هجمات إرهابية مروعة
تذبح النساء والأطفال
وكنت واضحا جدا في
إدانة حماس ولكن هناك
مبدأ أساسي ل  ما أعتقده هو أن عباس
ليس الشعب الفلسطيني ويجب
أن تكون قادرًا على التمييز بين حماس
والشعب الفلسطيني، وبالتالي لا يمكنك
استخدام الأشياء المروعة التي فعلتها حماس
كسبب لعقاب جماعي
للشعب الفلسطيني ومن ثم
يكون هناك  البعد الثاني الذي أعتقد أنه
مهم للغاية وما كنت أقوله قد
تم تحريفه بالكامل أه وكنت
أقول أن هناك مظالم
للشعب الفلسطيني بالطبع هناك قلت دعني
أقتبس منك قلت
أنه من المهم الاعتراف  إن
هجمات حماس لم تحدث من
فراغ، لذا أخبرنا ما هو
السياق بالطبع هناك مظالم
تتعلق بـ 56 عامًا من الاحتلال
والمستوطنات التي يتم بناؤها وعمليات
الإخلاء والافتقار التدريجي للأمل
لدى الشعب الفلسطيني في أنه
سيكون هناك  يكون حل الدولتين ولكني
قلت في نفس الجملة ولكن لا شيء من
هذه المظالم يبرر
الهجوم الهمجي لحماس وهو أمر
مثير للاهتمام للغاية لأنه عندما
تعلق الحكومة الإسرائيلية أو
السفير على هذا الأمر فإنهم يضعون
الجزء الأول من  الجملة لكنهم
حذفوا الجزء الثاني من الجملة ومن
الواضح أن الهجمات الوحشية التي تشنها حماس
لا تبرر العقاب الجماعي
للشعب الإسرائيلي ومظالم
الشعب الفلسطيني لا تبرر
الهجمات البربرية التي يقوم بها أماس، يجب أن
نتمسك بالمبادئ، أليس كذلك؟
مبدأ الإيمان إذا جاز لي أن أقصد في وجه
الله حياة أي شخص لها نفس
القيمة سواء كان أمريكيا برتغاليا إسرائيليا
أو
فلسطينيا هل تعتقد أن
الحصار أه قطع الطعام والكهرباء والوقود
وهذا القصف هذا هو
فعليا عقاب جماعي ل  2.2
مليون شخص،
الحقيقة هي أننا شهدنا
الرد الإسرائيلي في
غزة والقصف المتواصل ونشهد
عددًا هائلاً من
الضحايا المدنيين والقانون
الإنساني الدولي واضح.
يحظر القانون الإنساني الدولي أخذ
الرهائن وأنا أناشد بقوة
من أجل ذلك.  إطلاق سراح الرهائن الفوري وغير المشروط
من قبل حماس، ولقد
كنت دائمًا واضحًا جدًا بشأن ما
ينص عليه القانون الإنساني الدولي وهو
أنه لا ينبغي استخدام الدروع البشرية من قبل
الأطراف، وأنا أدين بشدة حقيقة
أن حماس تستخدم الدروع البشرية ولكن
القانون الإنساني الدولي
يمنح أيضًا  الأولوية لحماية
المدنيين وهذا ما لا
يحدث ذكرتم مقبرة
الأطفال التي كنت
أستخدمها الآن كما أه ربما تعرفون كل
عام أنشر تقريراً عن أطفال
قتلوا وتشوهوا وأقصد
ضحايا  الصراع والدول
التي تفعل ذلك
مدرجة أم وهذا عادة ما يولد
اجتماعا تذكر المواقف السابقة للمملكة العربية السعودية
من إسرائيل من روسيا الخ الآن
في السنوات السبع التي كنت فيها أمينًا
عامًا في التقارير التي تم
تقديمها بأقصى عدد من  الأطفال الذين
قتلوا خلال عام واحد من أي طرف من أطراف
النزاع كان حوالي 600 600 على يد
طالبان في أحد السنوات 600 على يد
الحكومة السورية وحلفائها في
آخر من السنوات إذا كنت تتذكر
الجدل حول الضجة حول
القصف السعودي في أه  في اليمن 300
شخص في عام واحد الآن لن
أدخل في نقاشات حول
دقة الأرقام التي قدمتها
سلطات الأمر الواقع الموجودة في غزة
أه لكن من الواضح أن عدد
الأطفال الذين قتلوا في أسابيع قليلة في غزة
أصبح من الواضح الآن أن
حماية المدنيين التي تحظى بأهمية
قصوى في القانون الإنساني الدولي
ليست ذات أهمية قصوى في الاستراتيجية
التي يتم تطبيقها من خلال
العمليات العسكرية في غزة. لماذا تعتقد، لماذا
تعتقد أن الإسرائيليين لا يقومون
بالحماية؟  عدم جعل ذلك أولوية
OB يعني لأن المنطق كان في
كثير من المواقف لرفع أه الحي
وأنا أفترض أن هذا لتسهيل
حركة القوات أو لأي
سبب آخر ولكن السؤال هو
حماية المدنيين المطلوبة
ليست هناك  ومن ثم فإن الجانب الثاني
في القانون الإنساني الدولي هو
أنه يجب عليك ضمان الوصول غير المقيد
للمساعدات الإنسانية إلى جميع
المناطق التي يدور فيها الصراع
وما رأيناه حتى الآن هو
قطرة بعد قطرة في الزيادة في
عمر المساعدات الإنسانية أم حتى  اليوم لدينا
حوالي 900 شاحنة أه في هذه الـ 22
يوم 930 شاحنة قبل ذلك في
الماضي كان هناك 500 شاحنة كل يوم
تمد غزة، يمكنك أن تتخيل ماذا
يعني هذا بالنسبة للمياه بالنسبة
للطب بالنسبة للطعام بالنسبة
للوقود  غير مصرح به
ولهذا السبب في كثير من المستشفيات
لدينا مشاكل مع أه الحاضنات
لديك مشاكل في غسيل
الكلى أه لديك أه
نقص التخدير وأشياء أخرى كثيرة
تحول أه هذا الوضع
إلى وضع مروع للغاية
لأهل غزة و  كما
قلت لا يمكنك الخلط بين
حماس التي يجب أن تدينها
وشعب غزة الذي يجب أن
تحميه هل تقلق من تصعيد
أه في لبنان في أماكن أخرى أنا
قلق للغاية أولا في
الضفة الغربية حيث الأمور  تزداد سوءا يوما بعد
يوم وحيث أه
نشهد مستويات من العنف
خطيرة للغاية ولكن بالطبع
الوضع الأكثر تعقيدا الذي نواجهه هو
فيما يتعلق بلبنان لقد كنا
نشطين للغاية في فعل كل ما في وسعنا مع
أولئك الذين يمكن أن يكون لهم تأثير  فوق أه
الطرفين أه كلا من الإصلاح وإسرائيل
للتأكد من أنهما في المستوى هل
تحدثت مع إيران لأن لديهم الكثير لقد
تحدثت مع إيران وطلبت
من إيران شيئين أحدهما هو
الضغط على أماس ليكون
الإفراج الفوري وغير المشروط عن الرهائن
وثانياً أقول لصباح لا يمكنك
خلق وضع فيه أه
سوف يغرق لبنان بالكامل في هذا
الصراع لأنه إذا كان الصباح سيشن
هجوماً واسع النطاق على إسرائيل فقد يخلق ذلك
لا أعرف نوع التأثير  ولكن هناك
شيء واحد أنا متأكد من أن لبنان لن ينجو
منه، هل يبدو أن الإيرانيين يستجيبون لذلك؟
لا أعلم أنهم لم يفعلوا ذلك، لقد
قالوا دائمًا إنه ليس لديهم ما
يفعلونه بما يحدث، لكنهم
يقولون علنًا أن هناك خطرًا من حدوث ذلك.  أم
هذا الصراع سيمتد لذلك أه
يعني أه دائما غامض جدا أه
موقف إيران لكن تحدثنا
مع صباح ونحن على اتصال وثيق
مع السلطات اللبنانية وكما
قلت يجب أن نفعل كل شيء لتجنب
التصعيد  المواجهة التي
ستكون عبارة عن هجوم هائل من esola
مع رد هائل من إسرائيل
سيتم فيه تدمير لبنان بالكامل
أه فكر في أنك
فقدت 100 موظف في الأمم المتحدة في
uh1 101 اعتبارًا من اليوم هل تشعر
أنك الآن أنت والأفراد  بعيداً عن
الأذى لا، على العكس من ذلك، الأعداد
تتزايد يوماً بعد يوم أه يمكنك أن
تتخيل ما هو معنى إدارة
منظمة حيث عندما يكون هناك شخص واحد
يعمل فقط للمساعدة في تلبية
الاحتياجات الإنسانية للناس،
يُقتل 101 شخص وبعض من
قتلوا مع عائلاتهم في
منازلهم بالقصف لذلك هذا
صعب جدا علينا سيكون لدينا عبر
المنظمة أه يوم الاثنين القادم دقيقة
صمت ستكون أعلامنا في النصف
يجب أه لكن أم بالطبع
يعني أنا أنعي كل الإسرائيليين الذين
قُتلوا على يد حماس، إنني أشعر بالأسى على جميع
الفلسطينيين الذين يموتون، ولكن كما
يمكنك أن تتخيل، أعني أننا عائلة
ونشعر بشكل
دراماتيكي للغاية بأولئك من عائلتنا الذين
يموتون، ويمكنك أن تتخيل مدى صعوبة
إخبار
زملائنا  أنهم يجب أن
يستمروا في هذا الوضع الخطير للغاية،
أنطونيو جوتيرز، شكرًا جزيلاً لك
على الانضمام إلينا، لقد كان من دواعي سروري